ми на глибині 437 метрів ми знаходимося
у місті де буде єдине у світі сховище
для остаточного заховання
відпрацьованого ядерного палива Протягом
наступних сотень тисяч років не буде
практично жодної небезпеки цей тунель
глибоко під землею має змінити ситуацію
з ядерними відходами чверть мільйона
тонн ядерних відходів нині просто лежать
по всьому світу У деяких випадках вони
виділяють токсини в навколишнє
середовище і ніхто достеменно не знає що
з ними робити
крім фінів як Їм це вдалося
коли я вперше почула що фіни будують
сховище для ядерних відходів я подумала
що воно буде десь у глибинці можливо за
Полярним колом але ні насправді це лише
3 години їзди автівки від Гельсінки у
муніципалітеті з населенням майже 10
тисяч осіб під назвою еу-райокі Тут
також знаходиться найбільший в Європі
ядерний реактор мені це палітет подав
заявку на розміщення майданчика і був
обраний серед чотирьох можливих місць
будівництво розпочалося у 2004 році
насправді будиночок сталося адже сховище
для остаточного зберігання
відпрацьованого ядерного палива має
утримувати високоредіактивні відходи від
витоку в навколишнє середовище протягом
кількох сотень тисяч років за цей час
настануть іминуть кілька льодовикових
періодів такий проєкт потребує
десятиліть обговорень планування
ретельного вибору майда підручників та
інженерного подвигу інші країни з
атомними електростанціями також шукали
власні постійні сховища але ніхто ще
навіть не розпочав будівництво Незалежно
від того чи є ви прихильником або
противником ядерної енергетики ця
проблема потребує швидкого вирішення
тому що у всьому світі відходи
накопичуються подекуди не підготовлених
тимчасових сховищах але не у Фінляндії
після десятиліть досліджень і
будівництва сховища яке фінською мовою
називається онколо тобто печера або яма
має запрацювати в найближчі кілька років
[музика]
ми готові
дорога вниз тай має майже 15 хвилин
ми спустилися на глибину 437 метрів
[музика]
тут дійсно наче в печері
навколо нас кристалічні корінні породи
суміш граніту та гірською породи під
назвою міг матиль і це перше підказка до
того Чому саме це місце було обрано для
зберігання ядерних відходів
білі майже два мільярди років Вона
досить непорушна досить суха вона тут не
так багато руху підземних
водсон головний Геолог у компанії яка
опікується об'єктом
вміщувальна порода немає бути економічно
вигідною для того щоб майбутні покоління
не хотіли б витягти її зі скелі але
знайти потрібну породу лише перший крок
адже ядерні відходи не схожі на будь-які
інші існує три основні типи ядерних
відходів низькоактивні середню активні
та високоактивні низькоактивні відходи
це зазвичай речі які контактували з
радіоактивними матеріалами наприклад
захисне обладнання Філь або медичні
відходи відходи середньої активності Це
обладнання що використовується на
атомних станціях або у виробництві зброї
наприклад труби чи ізоляційні матеріали
вони можуть залишатися радіоактивними
протягом кількох сотень років їх
дезактивують і ховають у низькоактивних
сховищах під землею або над землею до
99% усіх ядерних відходів підпадає під
цю категорію І лише 1% високоактивних
радіоактивних відходів є найбільш
проблематичним Вони складаються
здебільшого з відпрацьованих ядерних
паливних стрижнів але сюди також входять
відходи від виробництва ядерної зброї ці
відходи знаходяться або в басейнах
охолоджувачах або в сухих бочках загалом
понад чверть мільйона метричних тон це
стільки ж скільки важать 26 ейфелевих
веж
з деяких відходів витікає радіоактивний
матеріал
найкраще рішення для безпечного
поводження з ними поховати їх глибоко
під землею і залишити розкладатися на
кілька сотень тисяч років Поки вони не
стануть безпечними щоб запобігти витоку
радіоактивних відходів зі стрижнів за
цей час їх потрібно належним чином
укрити у Фінляндії відпрацьовані паливні
стрижні запечатують у мідні каністри
товщиною 5 см і висотою близько 5 метрів
потім їх транспортують під землю за
допомогою підіймача у корінних породах
вздовж дуже довгих тунелів сверблять
отвори потім каністри поміщають в отвори
Нічого собі тут так глибоко що я чую
власний відгумін отвір засипають
бентонітовою глиною яка також
використовується як наповнювач для
котячого туалету і може поглинати
грунтові води які можуть просочуватись
всередину і роз'їдати мідну каністру
тунель засипається тим самим матеріалом
і закриваються шестиметровою бетонною
плитою
ці капсули або контейнери найбільш
суперечливо складова всього сховища
ядерних відходів що станеться якщо шар
бентоніту матиме дефекти або буде
пошкоджений тоді грунтові води що
містять сульфіди та водень потраплять до
контейнерів у численних дослідженнях
вчені довели що мідь може піддатися
корозії і контейнери вийдуть з ладу
набагато швидше ніж розраховували
відповідальна компанія можливо вже через
десятиліття дослідження тривають і ця
тема широко обговорюється в науковій
спільноті але позиція фінського
агентства з ядерною безпеки та компанії
посіву в тому що ризик не надто значний
контейнер це лише один захисний шар з
багатьох наголошують вони
в онколо в майбутньому зберігатимуться
всі відходи з наявних фінських атомних
електростанцій наразі невідомо як
майбутні покоління зможуть визначити що
радіоактивні відходи знаходяться Саме
тут і чи потрібно їх зберігати не
маркованими та навіть Попри це Фінляндія
випереджає більшість країн можливо через
свій унікальний менталітет
може бути прагматичним мислення
фінського народу
що взаємний консенсус що ми повинні
дбати про відходи не залишати їх
майбутнім поколінням України
нічого не багато